no I can't I'm so sorry
wow that's really hard hi my name is
Kelsey Dempsey and I've been a free
stuff for over three years
hi my name is Earl I've been doing
coffee for about eight years
today I'm going to be creating some
latte from Instagram I got into being a
barista in college it's a part-time job
I went to Seattle when I was around 15
and I just started really getting into
third wave coffee
I feel pretty pretty nervous yeah but
good I'm like excited nervous like I
don't know what to expect which is like
exciting the biggest challenge will be
pouring pretty well with people watching
me let's get started
all right oh okay okay I can do that
okay challenge accepted
I'm feeling pretty excited I'm hoping
that this will work out I've always
wanted to do this I had to do this quite
often for a shop that I worked for
though that was your like signature
latte art and every time when people
order the drink they wanted that design
oh my goodness what a mistake but that
is okay
better than I thought you know just got
a roll with it you know if you spill
just keep going sorry I'm really [ __ ]
kind of looks like half dog half there
it brings back old memories sometimes
you do pour over a little bit and you
know just gotta keep going oh okay
you know I'm open I i I've never
actually done 3d before first I saw like
little shapes and stephannie like oh
yeah I can do that and then I saw that
and I'm like oh threw me a curve ball
alright so I'm probably just going to
steam a lot of milk so I have like
enough foam it's kind of like making a
meringue you want to incorporate a lot
of air I am a little fun vulnerable and
humbled I think this feels like an art
project
you know just testing the waters we do
this a on this project where wow that's
really hard I'm just gonna make a face
oh my gosh I'm so sorry no like the
things you see on Instagram aren't
always as easy as they look pretty
challenged good job Instagram beautiful
I can pick I am going to try that one so
- it's probably gonna do stats which is
basically like you have like you just
like stack different layers of milk
that's something I feel a lot more
confident
your workout under pressure it's a
little bit different I think the best
thing to do is start slow
[Music]
I mean it's not the same exact thing but
I like this one the trick is you need
it's kind of like a bowling ball you
want to like let it slide over the crema
with that like the the foam from the
milk will just kind of like fuse with
the creme of the espresso and it'll
float to the top of this making the
white part that what I feel good about
that one like if I serve to a customer I
feel yeah so I was going for the layered
bottom usual latte art it kind of like
strikes all the way through I feel like
this is just kind of my style I think I
did okay
yeah I think I could have done better I
would say I did as best as I could I
think it on like one but like you know
yeah okay I think trying to recreate
that 3d bear was the hardest thing I
would say in terms of feasibility I
would say the second one was probably
the hardest I'm definitely gonna
practice I think personally if you
really want to learn Lots they are just
like watching videos on Instagram it
took me maybe a solid like a year and a
half two years of just wasting milk
nobody really wanted to train me to do
that because I was so young but I kind
of trained myself and prove myself
please don't order 3d you'll get your
drink in 30 minutes
[Music]